the reason I got into this sport is to
find out what is possible for my mind
and my body I had no clue what I was
doing but I enjoyed the process of
improving this coach pulled me aside he
has me grab onto his uh paddle Bo and he
goes you could win this race one day
this my friends is incredible Chelsea
sedoro you become this sort of role
model and inspiration to not just female
athletes but like young moms across the
world like this notion like you can do
both you can do it all you think that
when you have this big success it's like
you kind of have unlocked the recipe and
now you know how to win and you'll just
keep on winning I'm supposed to be super
mom right I just won Iron Man world
you're the Iron Man world champion you
know super mom and and you can't leave
your
house I thought like this isn't right
it's like affecting my day-to-day life
I'm not as happy as I expected to
be when you can't enjoy the special
moments of your life it's not good A lot
of the time I still struggle I'm still
figuring it out but but I you know I
want my daughter to see what it looks
like to you know follow your dreams and
and go all in on what makes you feel
alive Hi Chelsea thank you for doing
this thank you so much for having me
it's um
it's a little bit surreal I'll be honest
with you come on well I have to tell you
a funny story maybe not that funny but
um I got into Triathlon kind of in my
late 20s sort of later in life and um
when I was first exploring the idea I
like found some books to like see what
triath was all about and I read two
books I read Siri linley's book and I
read Finding Ultra and that was kind of
one of my initiations
this CRA sport that we do so it's really
yeah wonderful to be that makes me very
happy I'm glad to hear that well uh you
um didn't need any of my input to do
what you do uh you've made quite an
impact on the sport and a relatively
short period of time I mean you got into
Triathlon in
2017 uh you know on the heels of a track
and field and cross country career very
storied in that regard as a runner um
but really I should just contextualize
for people who are watching or or
listening who who aren't immersed in the
sport of triathlon so they understand
you know who who who you know who is the
guest today um in
2022 you were the first rookie uh to
become world champion at uh Iron Man and
cona since Chrissy Wellington the first
American since 1996 that was Paula newb
Frasier and this was only the second
Iron Man of your career you were 33
years old uh and you were the first
American to win since Tim de boom in
2022 2002 and this occurred only 18
months after giving birth to
Sky um you didn't think you were going
to
win uh you ended up winning and
interestingly this Victory created a
major news story that transcended the
sport of triathlon and kind of put you
under the spotlight in mainstream way
that probably was disorienting and might
have surprised you um but it was a
really remarkable story and yet at the
same time there was a lot going on
behind the scenes and a lot has happened
since then which is you know one of the
more interesting things about you and
why I wanted to talk to you today so
first of all like congrats on this you
know amazing career and this Arc that
you're on um and I just wanted to check
in with you see how you're feeling and
you know how you feel about kind of
talking about the mental health aspect
of of what has been transpiring with you
for the last couple
years yeah well that's all um very kind
I'm in a really good spot it's it's so
interesting because I was not in a good
place after I won Kona last year and
this season has been so up and down for
me you know you think I've been in this
game long enough that I should have
known better but you think that when you
have this big success it's like all up
from here and you kind of have unlocked
the recipe and now you know how to win
and you'll just keep on winning and that
hasn't been my experience this year it's
been kind of a a rocky road with many
mistakes and I think there's some
element of luck in sport where the
pendulum has to swing your way and it
hasn't really for me this year but
ironically even after a disappointing
race in Kona this season I'm in a much
better heads space than I was last year
yeah so this year at Kona you placed
sixth correct um but you also said that
it's your proudest
finish like I was saying this year has
been really hard from a performance
athletic standpoint it took me a long
time to find my mojo again with some of
the mental health struggles I faced
earlier in the year and I would have you
know a training block or a performance
where I thought okay I'm back I'm
feeling like myself again and then I
would have some sickness or an injury or
some obstacle and I would think it's
fine like the only thing that matters is
Kona and you just need to get to that
training block ready to go and kind of
miraculously I did that I had um the
best training block of my life and then
picked up an injury two weeks out from
Kona and you know that's not to make
excuses like part of this game is
staying healthy that's a talent and a
skill and I wasn't able to pull that off
this year but even as I kind of saw the
the race slipping away from me I didn't
quit on myself and and someone said to
me after the
race the kind of signs of a true
champion is when you give everything
even when you see the wind slipping out
of your grasp and I think I I did that
this year so I'm not happy with the
result but I'm I'm really proud that I
gave it everything and it's hard to do
that for eight and a half hours well you
also punctuated it with a 253 run which
was the second fastest of the day so
clearly you didn't give up you to you
you basically laid it all out there I
did it's funny the games you play with
yourself when you're
racing I knew at a certain point that I
wasn't going to win but I created my own
challenges in the race and I have never
fought so hard for sixth place in my
life I passed I ran into sixth place
with 2K left to go and I was like using
all these tactics I used to do when I
was running and um buried myself and I
think that it will be a career defining
moment for me I don't think that I would
have done that six months ago I don't
think I would have had like the mental
strength and head space to do that I
think I would have pulled the plug and
and that's encouraging and exciting for
me moving forward so you're an
internally motivated person in other
words it's not uh who you're racing
against that gets you excited it's more
coming from a place of curiosity around
your own capacity is that is that
accurate I think so I'm not a perfect
person and I'm hyper competitive and I
hate losing but the reason I got into
this sport is to find out what is
possible for my mind and my body and I
really see it as this second chance at a
pro sports career which is is very rare
and I feel a lot of gratitude that I get
to do this at this level at this stage
in in my life that's a healthy
perspective it's taking a while to G
it's we're gonna get into it Chelsea
don't worry I'm gonna poke the bear but
let's take it back a little bit first uh
you you came up as a runner you grew up
in Davis
um you had success in track and field
and cross country some Stellar success
but at some point you make the decision
to transition into Triathlon so what was
that thought process all about for
you I had a couple of moments of
Brilliance in my professional running
career I won a couple of national titles
and then I proceeded to get injured and
I couldn't stay healthy I couldn't
really find the right training setup and
I had the worst day on the most
important day at the Olympic trials in
2016 and my husband and I were watching
the Olympics from our couch I was banged
up again and we tuned into the triathlon
and I had kind of become a fan of the
women because they were all metal
favorites and especially with Gwen
Jorgenson coming from a running
background and my husband looked at me
and he said I think you could do that
you are always cross training so you
know how to swim and bike and you just
put it together and you'll be great and
I laughed at him and I thought it was
the dumbest idea
but like most Tri athletes I got
obsessed and he got me a bike and we
were living in flagstat for the time
actually and he's a very talented
athlete himself he ran a sub for Miler
sub Miler All-American and the stle
Chase he is like surely the most
talented athlete in our family I just
happen to have like a great work ethic
but uh I would sit on his wheel for as
long as I could and I'd be like tasting
blood at the end of our rides and I
joined a master's group and and
ultimately got put in touch with this um
itu coach and he said come like try out
for my squad I think he saw my 10K time
and I went and trained with his squad
for a week and he was like can you be
here in December and uh yeah like within
a month we had upred our life I know
it's in retrospect like um I hadn't done
a triathlon yet and I blew and I you're
already like plugged into this world
that you don't have any experience in I
mean I looked back at photos and um I
mean I had no was I had no clue what I
was doing like there's certain like
etiquette to cycling that you learn
about and like I I mean I just looked
ridiculous I was still like occasionally
falling o falling over at stoplights
like clipping out of the pedal um but I
loved it and I think my running ability
transferred to the bike really quickly
and I I enjoy the process of improving
and I was kind of thrown into the the
deep end and with running to like
improve my 5K time by a couple seconds
that's maybe years of work and it may or
may not happen depending on getting into
the like if you get into the right race
and the conditions whereas I was seeing
big gains in the pool and on the bike
every single week yeah that's fun that
itu world though is a whole thing you
know it's it's very different for people
that don't know you know in terms of in
terms of how it measures up to something
like Iron Man it's all about bike
handling skills and staying in the path
and you know being a a runner of your
caliber I'm sure is like a secret weapon
in that world but uh that is a you know
different type of sport almost
altogether versus long course it it sure
is and I quickly realized that I was
going to have to live this sort of
nomadic lifestyle of going to from
training camp to training camp and the
races all were all over the world and I
was kind of trying to make the start
lless so I would have to just go
wherever I could get in and about 18
months in I won a World Cup and at this
point my husband and I were living apart
because he had to work I was making no
money and so um I'm at this race I win
it's supposed to be really exciting and
kind of the Launchpad for my career and
I'm by myself I'm not having any fun and
I decide to quit Triathlon and this
lasts for about two weeks until I'm
talked into doing a 70.3 ah who talked
you into
that I think my husband Steve like
definitely encouraged the idea cuz he
had seen the progress that I was making
and then I I moved back from San Diego
to the Bay Area to be with Steve and I
got connected with a coach there Matt
Dixon and he he saw what I had
accomplished so far and thought like
this girl could so you became part of
the whole Purple Patch situation I was
for yeah for a little while there which
was at the
time the right thing for me because I I
had been like pretty lonely and isolated
following this Olympic track and I
immediately had this community I had
training partners and um it was
initially just really fun MH at some
point though doesn't Dave Scott end up
giving you some advice like your mom
went to high school with Dave Scott yeah
so my mom grew up on the same street as
Dave Scott and Dave apparently would
come train in her backyard pool swim
laps and I think he played water pool
they had a net set up there and she's
remained in touch with him for forever
and when I was first thinking about
getting his Triathlon I called him and I
said Dave I'm thinking of trying
Triathlon what do you think and he goes
what can you swim for 10 by 100 and I
said I have no idea and he said I think
you should go for it if you're excited
about it just just try he's like forget
about that question anyway he was like
call me you seem excited yeah he's like
call me back if you ever like figure out
what you can swim for 10 by 100 but if
you feel good about it then sure why not
and then weren't you like didn't you
rent like a room in his old house or
something like there's just a weird it's
I'm asking that only because like
there's like some kind of universal
synchronicity happening that was
ushering you towards this life that you
now have I know it's pretty wild but um
when I
was s or8 months pregnant my husband
started fire academy and so and that was
I don't know 45 minutes away from where
my parents lived so we decided to rent
this little garage apartment two doors
down for my parents so that I could have
some help when the baby came because he
was in this full-time school thing and
it happened to be Dave Scott's old house
so and you didn't know that going in or
you no I knew that I knew that his
family doesn't live there anymore but I
knew that that was his house and and we
definitely have a special connection
interesting so how long before you from
the moment that you decide okay I'm
going to get into this longer course
world how long before you're seeing
results
there my first
7.3
was well before I did my first 70.3 I
went to a training camp in Kona with
this woman named Sarah pan piano who is
um a successful former long-distance
athlete and I had no money and when I
quit I I was like I'm not going on
training camps anymore like I don't want
to do that I just want to be home and
Matt talked me into going to this thing
he's like I think you'll have a good
time it'll be really fun you'll get like
a taste of what longdistance training is
like and so I went to Kona with Sarah
for her prep and I loved it and the
coach who was there I think kept on
expecting me to get dropped and I did I
would just like hang on for dear life
for all of her rides and I acclim wed
the heat really well so the running was
fine and I was swimming well and this
coach pulled me aside during one of the
Open Water Swim sessions and he said
Chelsea come here and I was like am I in
trouble what did I do he's like come
over here and he has me grab onto his uh
paddle board and he goes you could win
this race one day wow and I guess like
from that moment I thought okay you know
when someone like believes in you in
that phase of your career where I was
kind of coming off this challenging
situation that I'd been in with the itu
experience and exploring this new sport
when someone believes in you in that way
it's pretty empowering and um my first
proper 70.3 was Indian wells in 2018 and
I won and I thought like the first one
right out of the gate that's
unbelievable you had some swimming
background though right when you were a
kid I I did I grew up in Davis like we
talked about and um every kid does
summer swim league we have this program
called Summer darts and my brother and I
were both thrown in it I think my
parents wanted us to be like proficient
swimmers and my brother is a very
talented swimmer he ended up playing
waterpool at the Air Force Academy I did
not enjoy the swimming I was not good at
it um but I at least had that sort of
feel for the water knowing how to do it
I think so it's huge it's really hard to
learn that later in life yes yes
absolutely um but I think I am lucky in
the sense that I still really enjoy
swimming you know like a lot of my peers
who come from a swimming background
totally dread getting in the water like
they've put in so many hours in the pool
that it's a necessary evil of
participating in Triathlon whereas I
still enjoy it I still feel young in
that aspect so 2018 your first 70.3 you
win basically it's still four years
before you win Kona but in that period
of time you only do one Iron Man I
assume in the season leading up to the
20 in during the 2022 season right so
you spend a little bit of time in that
70.3 Arena and then decide to take it up
a notch to Iron Man yeah so I had this
breakthrough season in 2019 where I won
a bunch of 703s and I was fourth at the
world championships in nce and and
thought the world is my oyster like this
is my thing if I can get fourth in my
first one like next time I'm going to
crush and I was like kind of making
decent money I would like pay off the
credit card bill that ID accumulated
when I was you know chasing the Olympic
dream um but of course in 2020 as we all
know Co hit and I was chasing Strava
qom like everyone else was doing and was
not that excited about it
and decided to get pregnant instead of
doing that mhm so that
definitely um yeah was a a big pivot if
there was ever a time though right
there's no races this is the moment you
wanted to be a mom you became a
mom but the idea was always that you
were going to return to training and
being a good hyperco competitive control
freak right you're like I'm going to
squirt this kid out and be back on the
bike you know imminently right but life
had another plan yeah absolutely I
started working with my current coach
Dan
ples when I was six weeks pregnant
actually and I'd been interviewing I
knew that I'd wanted to make a coaching
change and I'd been interviewing several
coaches and I called him to say like hey
Dan I think you're the perfect fit for
me let's work together side note I just
found out I'm pregnant and so I would
totally understand if you don't want to
take me on and we can re-evaluate a year
from now when I'm getting back into
things but he said no this is the best
news congratulations how can I support
you wow which is really rare in our
industry especially for a mail coach to
say that to a person and I think it
immediately established this level of
trust and he kind of coached me for the
first 20 weeks of my pregnancy and I
ended up having morning sickness for 35
weeks so it was really kind of up and
down we never like got much momentum and
of as I progressed through my pregnancy
I got more uncomfortable and I was able
to do less and less and finally was like
I think I just need to do what I feel
like and I'll call you when she's born
or whatever well I have a lot of
questions about that but my first
question is what what lured you towards
Dan to begin with like what were you
looking for in a coach what were the
needs that you you know were trying to
identify that he could fill for you I
really wanted a data driven approach and
Dan is
a world-class coach he's worked with all
types of different athletes including
cyclists
triathletes rowers kayakers but he's a
physiologist and when we chatted I I
really felt excited about his approach
and program MH and he also said to me
look Chelsea I went the same time
basically went the same time as Daniela
riff when she set the course record in
Kona in 2018 so I know exactly what you
need to do to win that race and and that
of course made me really excited yeah
well you seem like somebody who who
really like kind of you know in on this
subject of control like data is like
your music right like controlling like
I'm going to control not just the
controllables but the uncontrollables
too like this this I'm I'm gleaning from
you in the research that I did you know
kind of to get ready to speak to you
that um um that's sort of your operating
system your default operating system
yeah you know I'm a perfectionist and
I'm quite obsessive which I'm sure we'll
get
into but I actually so you're like Iron
Man perfect yeah this is thef yeah
exactly um but I'm actually I'm
personally not that interested in the
data and Dan will send me articles and
different research papers kind of
related to what we're doing and I would
say um sorry Dan but I I don't read most
of them because I I don't want to be a
coach when I grow up um I'm like not
that interested in the
physiology I I want to be able to have
so much trust in my coach that I can
just execute the plan and sort of check
out because I think that if I obsess too
much about the data and the numbers then
that will just take me down a rabbit
hole that's not productive and I need to
have space outside of training so um I
am involved in my program and and what I
do but I have so much trust in Dan that
he's leading me down the right path that
I can kind of execute the training and
then move on it it it almost sounds like
a level of self-awareness like I know
I'm a control freak I know I'm a
perfectionist so I'm actually not going
to read the data because that will just
like my brain will light up like a
Christmas tree because that's you know
what I mean like it's a it's it's like a
self-preservation thing like I don't
want to read the data you take care of
that because that's like a danger zone
for for my you know kind of proclivity
to want to control everything and
understand
everything yeah that's that's probably
fair and you know I'm pretty good at
swimming and biking and running but I
think one of my greatest talents is kind
of working or finding these amazing
people to work with and
delegating well and especially this
season coming off the Kona win I've had
more opportunity and more resources to
kind of build my team which has been
super fun MH so you start working with
Dan uh 35 weeks it was rough morning
sickness I I think I was really cocky
going into pregnancy I remember saying
to my mom who is a family doctor and
practiced OB for 20 years I said Mom
this is going to be like vacation I'm
used to training 30 hours a week
pregnancy is going to be like a break
for me and it was not a not a break it's
really it's um yeah a physical feat and
I also thought that I would be able to
check out from my Sport and not really
worry about getting behind but that was
more difficult than I expected as you
see um yeah your body change in such
dramatic ways so quickly everybody's
different I can remember being in master
swimming you know over many many many
years and there'd be women who would
come in they get pregnant pregnant and
then literally like they're going to pop
but they're at Master swim practice and
then they're gone for like a week and
then they're back you know like so for
some people maybe it is a lot easier but
that was not your experience yeah it is
so individual and I get a lot of women
reaching out to me asking for advice on
how to train through pregnancy and how
to train after pregnancy and it's it's
not a one siiz fits-all approach have to
learn to listen to your body and you
know I I remember Dan trying to give me
some sessions in my first
trimester and I would like have to get
off the bike to go puke in the yard like
in between intervals and you're like
what are we really accomplishing here
yeah but but of
course training makes me feel like
myself and I think we are learning more
about what's possible for women and that
we should be moving our bodies and we
can exercise size through pregnancy we
just have to like figure out what feels
good right but there's a different
playing field to understand there's not
a template that applies to everybody and
certainly not the template that would
apply to the male athlete that can't be
just transferred to the pregnant woman
who's you know in the same
sport yeah through this experience I
really learned
how the Health Care system is not set up
for us
how um there isn't really research done
on female athletes on the postpartum
athlete and I feel lucky to have
connected with some experts who could
sort of guide me
but it's really it's really tough and I
was surprised how much I had to advocate
for myself how like I really had to like
seek out help both kind of physically in
the postpartum return to competition and
also like on the mental health side mhm
postpartum it wasn't just a difficult
pregnancy postpartum be it even became
more challenging with this lactation
issue and many many visits to the to the
pediatrician trying to figure out you
know what the latching issue was like
you went through a whole thing with that
as well yeah there's this great little
clip of me walking around the block with
my dog when I'm nine and a half months
pregnant and I'm saying so here's what's
GNA happen I'm gonna like push this baby
out and then I'm GNA get back to
training in three or four weeks once you
know I'm Healed and then I'm going to do
70.3 Boulder at four months postpartum
and that's going to qualify me for the
Collins cup which was this new team Race
that was happening and I was going to be
five months postpartum and uh to be
frank like I really needs to race
because my husband was in school and we
needed to pay our bills and I felt like
I was missing the the 2020 season and I
couldn't miss the 20 like all of the
season and so there was already this
level of pressure on there that I needed
to get back to work and things were
challenging from the beginning we spent
less than 24 hours in the hospital my
daughter hadn't latched properly by the
time we were discharged and it felt like
we were kind of just being like kicked
out of the hospital like everything
seemed fine and everything was not fine
and within a couple days of my
daughter's birth she was below the 10th
percentile of her weight which is very
scary we couldn't figure out how to
breastfeed and I think a lot of mothers
experienced this you have this idea of
what parenting is going to look like
what breastfeeding is going to look like
what kind of raising a child is going to
look like and it becomes apparent very
quickly that it's not about what you
want like it's there there's two of you
that have to work together
and it was it was so gnarly I mean like
we were feeding her with a syringe my
husband would leave at 400 in the
morning for fire academy and get home at
p.m. our kid wasn't eating like I was in
yeah with the lactation therapist every
other day I'm starting to develop this
pretty severe anxiety probably related
to the sleep deprivation and the stress
of like trying to feed my kid and um
it was kind of like yeah a spiral from
there and I
think I felt a lot of pressure
to be excellent like that's what I do I
work hard and I set goals and whatever I
put my mind to I can accomplish and like
I'm an Iron Man athlete I can tell you
with full confidence that I have never
worked harder at anything in my life
than trying to breastfeed my child wow
that's humbling to hear and it took a
long time to kind of solve that problem
and find find somebody who understood
what was actually happening yeah well we
didn't Sol I mean we didn't solve like
the breastfeeding problem we learned
that she had a posterior tongue tie and
we found this pediatric dentist it was
very expensive we had to pay for all the
stuff out of pocket and that ended up
being a really traumatic experience
because he he like did this laser
procedure where they like open up the
tongue tie and when we went back to do
her followup he just reached into her
mouth and ripped up her tongue and
reopened the wound on a you know 10day
old
baby and
um that was like quite upsetting for me
and the state that I was in this is the
first time I actually
remember this fear that was
developing of mass shootings and I was
in this dentist's office like so afraid
about something going down and um yeah
that like evolved into this whole
anxiety situation for me how long of a
period of time did that unfold in like
you you said like you've always been
sort of an anxious person um but there's
a difference between you know some level
of lowgrade anxiety and and something
that is severe and and chronic that's
escalating into a lot of kind of
irrational fears that are debilitating
you yeah I used to just call
it being stressed out and as I reflect
on my life like some of the things I've
learned over the past year or so make
more sense
but the yeah the anxiety the postpartum
anxiety was certainly
affecting how I was living my life I
didn't want to go into like a grocery
store I had a really hard time being in
enclosed spaces which became tough since
I had to go to the doctor's office so
often so I would just be in the waiting
room with Sky um like crying waiting for
them to let us
in the like the room and I would always
be checking for exits and how I was
going to get out of places um so I was
having to confront this a lot because I
was always in the doctor's office and I
realized that I needed to get some help
so I and this is before the 2022 Iron
Man probably I was probably six weeks
postpartum at this point when I thought
like this isn't right it's like
affecting my day-to-day life I'm not as
happy as I expected to be like having
just brought my daughter into the world
you know you think like you have this
new baby and you're so in love and you
should be so joyful but I wasn't I was
super anxious
and I tried to get like some sort of
mental health help through my
insurance and this proved to be
virtually impossible to get everyone on
the phone it's a nightmare anyone on the
phone it was a nightmare yeah and this
is in 2021 so kind of peak
pandemic so many people are in Mental
Health crisis and I wasn't able to get
anyone on the phone so I seek out um uh
an EMDR
therapist who um was close to where I
lived at the time and it was very
expensive I was paying out of pocket but
I was really desperate and someone had
told me like EMDR will be a great option
for you because obviously there's some
like trauma there and they can teach you
to like retrain your brain rewire your
brain so I thought great and this lady
you know agreed to take me on
and I
felt like optimistic when I first went
in that I finally was able to get some
help but um once we got into things I
felt a lot of judgment like my um you
know my issues weren't valid and um
that yeah I was just being totally
unreasonable which isn't something
that's like the antithesis of of how you
should be welcomed into the office of a
mental health practitioner right it's
about non-judgment and understanding and
creating an environment where you feel
safe right how are you supposed to heal
if yeah and I almost got threatened when
you go there right I almost got this
sense that like my issues weren't bad
enough like it wasn't like traumatic
enough and um of course like I don't
know what other kind of patients or
you're lying and you're not telling the
truth about the real trauma that you're
hiding yeah I don't I don't know what
place she was coming from but um I did a
couple sessions with her and then I I
had to go to training camp and I was
like thanks for the help um this has
been good but like I got to go I got to
go work and so you saw you got no relief
from that modality no and I kind of
thought like I've
tried I guess like yeah my issues aren't
serious enough I just need to like
figure this out and I'll you know do
some meditation and hopefully it gets
better yeah you you tapped into some
viic meditation right I did you got your
Mantra and the whole thing I do yeah
yeah yeah yeah I was connected with this
like amazing teacher in Marin County
like right before the pandemic which
which was certainly a gift but I
think you can't always exercise and
meditate your way out of a mental health
[Music]
crisis I'm curious around the the
training piece
because I would presume as a competitive
athlete like yourself on some level
you're you're harboring this belief that
you can just train your way out of that
knowing that like you said like you know
I need to train to feel like myself like
I understand that I like we were sharing
before the podcast and I was telling you
about my lower back that has me
sidelined more than I'd like right now
and and when I'm not able to go out and
push myself I don't feel like the best
version of who I am my brain doesn't
function the same way Etc um but play
that out you know
to the extreme this idea that well if I
just you know get back to doing what I
love and I can kind of control that
environment that all these other things
will get resolved that
way yeah yeah I think you hit the nail
on the head I had hadn't been able to do
my job for a year basically and and I
felt a real pressure to get back to to
work and racing but I also felt like I
needed to prove to myself that I could
still do it it and if I could still
compete if I could still train like I
wanted to then things would get better
and I would feel like myself again and
everything would be fine and there were
certain stages between that initial
postpartum period until the Kona wi
where I convinced myself that it was
fine but at some point you realize
you're going to need something
more yeah when I was at the awards
ceremony at Kona in 2020 too I turned to
my husband and I
said how are we going to get out of here
if someone starts shooting up this
banquet get out honest yeah and um
that's a problem I think when you can't
enjoy the special moments of your life
it's not good when you can't be present
enough to appreciate like the
experiences and and people around you
it's a problem I'm I'm so sorry like
that's so painful to
hear thanks
I I I feel that and this is why I'm so
transparent about these
things I feel like so much of this could
have been
prevented if I had had access
to help
initially and I don't want women to
experience what I did and like I have
I'm a middle- class white woman like I
have a lot of access and resources and I
still like couldn't get a therapist on
the phone and like I had to advocate so
hard to get like treatment for my kid
you know and it shouldn't be that way
especially when you're in such a
vulnerable like postpartum State when
like you should just be enjoying your
baby and it doesn't seem like that big
of a problem to solve and yet our Health
Care system is so upside down and
Byzantine um and disorienting and all
the help that you need is on is on you
know the other side of your premiums
like it's it's it's like when you really
need help it's always the thing that's
not covered by your insurance you know
um you know I can't imagine how
challenging that's been for you and it's
actually you know reflecting on it and
understanding it a little bit better um
you know beyond kind of like the
articles that are on the internet about
this it's
absolutely mindblowing that you won that
race in 2022 that you were Iron Man
world champion given everything that was
going on it's not like you had some kind
of perfect season leading up to this
like you were going through a tremendous
amount that would have derailed the
strongest person in the field like it's
really quite
stunning thanks
I like I don't feel like a victim in
this situation and I don't mean to
portray you no no I know but I like I I
think that there's you know there is a
really like happy ending to the story
and I am in a good place and I was able
to get help but
um I think that you know like I won that
title in spite of a lot of obstacles
that I faced and
I'm like empowered by that certainly but
I also think like wow I wonder what I
could have done if I was in you know a
really like positive happy space
right you make this decision to not only
seek help but as you mentioned earlier
to be public about it to be transparent
about it um to share what you were
experiencing um which is a pretty bold
move for somebody who's still in the
sport you know and the sport is a mental
game as much as anything else like to be
that vulnerable you're letting your
competitors know that you have chinks in
your armor um so obviously there's a
there's a broader intentionality behind
this but when that article in the New
York Times came out by Matt futterman
who's a friend he spent on the podcast
uh shout out to Matt um that was really
powerful like that's you like in the in
the largest you know newspaper in the
world like being really open about
private matters so walk me through why
you made the decision to do that and
what your kind of hopes were for telling
your story in such a you know vulnerable
way I oftentimes train in my parents
Garage in Davis when I want to get out
of the winter and Reno where I live and
my dad sets up all of my like second and
third place trophies right in front of
where I can see I think like to piss me
off a little bit but right on the wall
behind these second and third place
trophies is a quote and it says we make
a living by what we get we make a Life
by what we give and I come from a very
service-minded family my mom is a family
doctor she went to med school when I was
one and so I've gone to front row seat
to this incredible woman who chose this
career and motherhood simultaneously and
had to navigate all of those challenges
that challenges that come along with
like that Pursuit at such a high level
um my dad is a high school teacher or
was a high school teacher before he
retired my brother is a special tactics
officer in the Air Force and my husband
is a trained firefighter so I'm you know
everybody's in public service and you're
in the most selfish pursuit of all time
exactly the self you have to balance
this equation somehow exactly and so
this has really bothered me like this
selfish Pursuit I mean it's all about me
and optimizing my training and my life
and my performance and um I've had a
hard time wrapping my head around that
and so now that I have this now that I
kind of earned this platform for lack of
a better word after the Kona win I I
thought like I need to do something
really good with this and Matt fman
who's just a really wonderful person
reached out to me after the race because
he wanted to do this story about my
coach Dan and our International
InterContinental relationship because my
coach lives in New Zealand and I'm based
in the US and we had a chat about cona
and how the race went down and my
training setup and he said I'll call you
in in a while to check in and see where
the stories at and he called me in
January of 2023 and he said hey Chelsea
how's it going what are you up to and I
was like things are okay I kind of had a
rocky road after Kona but I'm good now
and excited about the season and he was
like what do you mean things are okay
and I said well if I talk to you about
it are you going to write about it yeah
and he said maybe that's what I do and
for whatever reason I just was super
honest and kind of told him this story
about my postpartum anxiety and
depression and and this past that I
traveled to towards getting help with
this psychiatrist that I found in Reno
and that's what the story was about and
I was quite nervous for for it to come
out because like people some people who
are like you know good friends or family
didn't even like know what was going on
and it was it was very public
but I think from my perspective you know
if it like empowered one person
to reach out for help like job done was
worth it and it was also really freeing
for me in some ways because there's so
much shame around mental health there's
a lot of stigma
and I was able to sort of let go of that
in some ways because I had nothing to
hide I didn't have to perform
anymore and around this like Kona time
period and and right after the win you
know I was getting a lot of media
attention and I felt this real
dissonance
between my public life and what I felt
inside yeah and I think that just
perpetuates the cycle right and so when
I was able to just like say lay it on
the table this is what it is like
there's a catharsis and then suddenly
that dissonance dissipates because
you're integrated like how you're
holding yourself out publicly is
actually Who You Are
and I would imagine lightens your load a
little bit I think so
and I really feel like we're here to
help each other out and make things a
little bit better for each other a
little bit easier and I don't think I do
that by swimming and swimming and biking
and running but I can do that by like
being open about some of these things
and it's been really amazing to connect
with other women and moms and parents
and feel like I maybe like part of
something that's bigger than
myself the Press Onslaught in the
aftermath of 2022 was was this kind of
incessant celebration of you as the new
mom right you become this sort of role
model and inspiration to not just female
athletes but like young moms across the
world like this notion like you can do
both you can do it all and to internally
feel that you're struggling and then to
look at that must be strange but also
this call to service like this idea that
suddenly you have this platform and this
microphone because of this win it's put
you in a position where you have
leverage to you know kind of lean into
that service piece um
[Music]
which looks to me like it has two
Avenues on the one hand it's about
equity in sport and you know how can we
create a more welcome on-ramp for um
girls women females in sport in
Triathlon Etc Equity with respect to the
professional aspect of it and we can get
into you know the business aspect of of
what that looks like and this is all on
the heels of of you know kind of what
happened with Nike and the and the you
know they pregnant athletes Etc like
it's a new era there is a lot of
education and awareness around this and
with that opportunity to kind of write a
new script but the second piece being
this this whole idea around mental
health that for you has its origins in
in in your motherhood and in your
pregnancy but actually is a much broader
conversation around how we normalize you
know what goes on inside of us
internally but to come out and say you
know you were scared of going to public
places because there might be a mass
shooting like that's a heavy that's
heavy yeah I
think not to get political but like we
have some serious issues in this country
and um yeah like I won't I won't get
into gun control here but
um we are not like this country is not
set up for
moms
um
there like is still a massive gender pay
gap which is you know like that um gets
worse when when you have a baby because
you're out of the workforce for for a
period of time you miss out on
experiences promotional opportunities um
and uh we have a huge maternal mortality
crisis access to child care is horrific
um and and I really think that
sport is a microcosm of society as a
whole and that's why I do think it's
important for me to talk about my
experiences and what could have made my
experiences better because if we can do
that in like the arena of pro sports
when our bodies are our commodity what
could be
possible outside of sport in other
Industries the Alison Felix and Cara
Goucher situations with Nike created
massive awareness around this and and
you know I think a lot of companies Now
understand that they have to address
these concerns from a place of of of
Greater Equity but what is your sense of
how Progressive it is right now like
what has changed for the better and what
Still Remains to be
done a lot of people talk about how
Equitable Triathlon is because we have
equal priz money at most races but I
think if you peel back the curtain a
little farther it's not as Equitable as
one may think we're under ndas with all
of our contracts um it's hard to know
what maternity leave policies look like
from company to company if if you do do
choose motherhood um you may or may not
get paid of course like you do Miss miss
out on prize money and race bonuses
while you're pregnant and on and on
leave and I have felt so fortunate with
the people that I do work with how they
have embraced me as a mother how um you
know we have worked together to form
like Fair maternity policies but I still
don't think that is like standard
practice across the industry
it's so important though because as
female athletes like we peak in our mid
to late 30s and we're so valuable like
the spending power of you know moms in
this country is massive so around the
world is massive so it just like makes
sense from an economic standpoint it's a
matter of the decision makers deciding
that they're they want to invest in that
well you're almost like a case study in
that right because you being this new
mom who wins The Iron Man World
Championship um makes you an extremely
valuable commodity because your story
transcended the sport it's one thing to
win that race it's another thing for
normal people who don't care about
Triathlon to care about that athlete and
that story and that was something that
you succeeded in doing and I think that
speaks to the possibilities of of you
know motherhood and competitive
you know women athletes at the at the
elite highest level of sport and we
should just we should just call out like
your partners because they're great and
I share a couple of them on of course
teates Rich that's right um yeah I'm
running way behind you but uh on and
also Canyon uh you know your your um
your bike partner I mean they're both
really cool amazing companies that are
very Progressive and are are comprised
of extremely talented people
absolutely and and they've both really
been along on the ride with me this year
it's it's been I feel so supported as a
person and it's been kind of an up and
down season but I felt
like yeah really empowered and supported
through it all and and I think we are in
it together and there's a story to tell
Beyond just you know the race results
right and I and we all believe that My
best performances are ahead of me but in
order for you know fans to get attached
to athletes you have to tell the story
along the way and and that's been a fun
Journey it's just as important if not
more important than where you finish a
race like where on the podium you stand
I think that people want to see
themselves and you know their Sports
heroes or in professional athletes and
triathon is so cool because of our like
proximity longdistance Triathlon is so
cool because of our proximity to the
amateur field like we're all out there
racing together experiencing the same
things maybe at different speeds but
like the pain is the same across across
the board and
um it's interesting I think
that sometimes women like we we feel
like we need permission to carve out
time for ourselves especially when we're
moms like the mom guilt thing
is real and in in a small way I think
that I've I've been able to help someone
understand that like they deserve this
time for themselves and
that like doing things outside of
parenting doing things that like light
you up as a person it makes you a better
mom makes you happy happier person yeah
so that you're not like when you're out
training you're not guilt-ridden because
you're not with your child and being the
best mom that you can and when you're
with your child you're not guilt-ridden
about not pursuing your sport because
that's your job yeah exactly and like I
still struggle with these things yeah um
a lot a lot of the time I still struggle
I'm still figuring it out but but I you
know I want my daughter to see what it
looks like to you know follow your
dreams and and go all in on what makes
you feel
[Music]
alive there's an interesting um kind
of uh Dynamic at play when it comes to
uh someone like yourself like a a mother
of a young child who also happens to be
an extraordinary athlete where someone
like myself or a member of the press the
first question is always going to be
like how do you balance you know how do
you do both how do you be a mom and an
elite athlete and on the one hand that's
super annoying because no one asked the
males like how they how they're a dad
and you know do it it's just not but
there on the other hand there is
something really different and unique
about motherhood especially in those
early years like that Bond and you know
it's different for you than it is for
the men and that is worthy of a
conversation um but the treatment or the
I guess the the the way in which you
know that kind of inquiry is is
dispatched towards someone like yourself
probably isn't handled as as delicately
or as deafly as it should be yeah
there's certainly a Nuance
but I'm not necessarily offended because
I think that a lot of women want to know
how to do all of the things and I don't
believe in Balance I don't really have a
life outside of my family and training
you know I train 30 hours a week and I
have a toddler who goes to bed at 8 and
who takes a nap in the middle of the day
so there's not a lot of yeah space for
much else besides those two things and
that's the phase of life that I'm in and
that's what I've chosen to
do but the way this all happens is um my
amazing co-parent and my husband Steve
and he's he's just like the most
selfless person and has really gone all
in on this with me and I would quit
Triathlon so many times or I did quit
Triathlon so many times but he always
encouraged me and said like you just
need to keep on give it one more try and
like you're going to be amazing and just
hang in there um but he you know he
actually left his job this summer
because I I'm competing internationally
have to go go to all these training
camps and I was traveling with sky and
he was you know he's a firefighter so he
has this very bizarre schedule and we
had a hard time really hard time finding
child care so um yeah he's committed
to working with me on a day-to-day basis
in my career but also as a parent so
he's a really really unique and special
guy that's pretty cool yeah he's awesome
yeah very cool um well you seem like
you're in a really good place right now
um and I'm reflecting on on Matt's
article in the New York Times which you
know paints a pretty there's a you know
it gets pretty low and dark like some Su
suicide
audiation your experience you know kind
of flirting with ssris and and not
getting any kind of results um sure viic
meditation great like getting back into
training that's all good but how did you
find your way forward and begin to kind
of crawl out of that
Darkness yeah I had gone to see this um
physio that I worked with for many years
after Kona because I wanted to check in
on
you know my like body post Iron Man and
make sure things are firing well and he
did some like biometric testing on me
where I laid on the table and he hooked
me up to I think a hurry Mon and a sweat
test hurry mon heart rate a heart rate
monitor and a sweat test and he was kind
of taking me through these scenarios and
um I was asked to visualize like a
really stressful situation and you would
expect my heart rate to Skyrocket and
like my sweat rate to increase but my
heart rate just stabilized and he said
that's really weird like you shouldn't
be so like that shouldn't be so normal
for you and he said I think you need to
like and I had told him about some of
the anxiety stuff and he was like I
think you really need to get some help
like it's not normal that you are having
a hard time going to the grocery store
you shouldn't have to live this way and
so he found me uh psychiatrist in Reno
where I live and so it it kind of took
somebody else finding this person for me
and uh again it was like really
expensive I paid for it all out of
pocket and I only say that because I I
think it's important for people to know
like how hard it is to get like mental
health treatment and like we talked
about when you're at your kind of lowest
low it shouldn't be so difficult to like
get an appointment or when you're in
that state you don't have the facility
or capacity to go on this like diligent
hunt for the right person exactly
exactly so luckily this woman who I
found was an amazing fit for me and
she's actually worked with a number of
paralympic
athletes which is a little bit different
from what I do but she still had this
understanding of what I had accomplished
and what I was trying to achieve and so
she didn't just say like stop training
and like work on your mental health and
go from there she understood
what I was doing for work and um I I was
talking through her about my symptoms in
our first appointment and she said I
think I know what's going on and I was
like what like yeah I'm anxious what do
you mean what's going on she's like I
think you have
OCD and um that was very alarming for me
initially I think it's scary when you
have sort of a label to um an illness
but as I reflected more I thought okay
this makes a lot of sense and and with
OCD we often think of like incessant
handwashing or you know like tapping on
door knobs or these little like ticks
but for me it was you know an inability
to like control these obsessive thoughts
that were happening in in my mind like
the mass shooting thing and and the
thing about OCD is that if you don't
treat it it just kind of like permeates
into all these different areas of your
life so I was having a really hard time
time getting on an airplane and um I was
really like starting to get paranoid
about certain things and so it was like
going Beyond just this one
initial thing and and so she taught me
some like strategies that I could use to
like help and also put me on a really
low dose of of an anti-anxiety
medication which terrified me there is
like so much stigma around um medication
and I had all of these ideas of what it
could do to me and how like I might gain
weight and that would affect my
performance and um I might like be
really I don't know I might like change
my personality and she said to me at one
point like what you're doing right now
is not working for you so I think you
need to figure out some other strategies
and like I don't care how much of this
pill you take like cut it into quarters
if you need to but this is part of the
treatment like
now this is
becoming like an
obsession wow just take like whatever
like take a quarter of the pill this is
part of the treatment and so ultimately
I was you know it's like you have to you
almost like have to decide for yourself
like I don't want to live this way
anymore and
um yeah like what other options do I
have right also what does it say about
you if you have to take this pill in
order to deal with this problem as
somebody who who you know I'm sure
thinks of yourself as a very strong
person who can Will her way through
anything yeah exactly and I had been
kind of white knuckling it for for so
long at that point I think over a year
and a half
and and I really hit this kind of like
ultimate low for me where I had no joy
in my day-to-day life I was getting
suicidal
ideations I couldn't really go into
public places and like I'm supposed to
be super mom right I just won Iron Man
world you're the Iron Man world champion
you know super mom you know in People
magazine and exct you can't leave your
house right
wow yeah
so what was the uh efficacy of this like
I assume it worked yeah I can pinpoint
the day in my training calendar when I
when you know the meds kicked in uh-huh
it has to like tie trate up for a while
before you it takes 10 days or two weeks
or something thing and I was telling
someone the other day I was like I'm on
a really low dose like five I Take 5
milligrams of lexipro every day and I
said to someone I don't know if it
actually is doing anything because it's
such a small dose and they said that's
kind of like besides the point if you
feel better and your symptoms are better
then it's doing something even if that's
just a placeo um but yeah it's pretty
wild I can I wasn't able to like I was
having a hard time getting out of bed in
the morning I
like couldn't go I couldn't train like I
was so low I was not I could not get out
for a run um and then I can see you know
in the calendar we like oh yeah I'm I
can train again wow Lexapro lexo that's
all it took I
know no it shouldn't have been that hard
to figure that out I know right but
that's like uh man I mean I also learned
like a lot of a lot of other strategies
uhhuh
to to deal with this and I mean does it
still flare up or you have like moments
of es and flows with it I do and I think
it will be something that I deal with
for the rest of my life like on one hand
it's my superpower it's this
obsessiveness makes me really excellent
what I do like you know all the was
there a fear like if I take this and it
reduces that obsessive nature then
that's going to undercut like what makes
me great at the thing that I'm best at I
think what's really sick is I had this
fear that um this kind of Darkness was
part of why I was so driven and I
thought that if I lose that I might not
have the desire anymore that's the great
fear of every person that wanders into
an AA meeting or an NA meeting
especially creative people and artists
because they believe that it is you know
the darkness or the altered state of
mind that is what is producing what
makes them unique and successful uh and
of course that's the great lie like you
have to disabuse yourself of that idea
and realize that it's not that maybe
there was some kind of short-term you
know positive effect of leveraging that
and kind of deploying it in a certain
direction But ultimately it becomes your
enemy and to find a more sustainable
healthy source of fuel um is a pretty uh
um it's like an Awakening right and it
sounds like you've had your version of
that I think so and and
ultimately it was about more than just
sport it was really about my daughter
because I wasn't enjoying her and I
wanted to be present and I wanted
her to feel that Joy kind of emanating
from me and I was really afraid that if
I didn't choose a different
path I would
just I would not be what she
deserved and and that was like my real
motivation it wasn't about like being
able to continue on in Triathlon it was
about showing up for for
her yeah all the other people that are
affected you know the ripple effect of
somebody who has loved ones in their
lives who is suffering and it just makes
me wonder or think about all the people
that are walking around with some
version of your condition untreated when
there's a solution available but for
whatever reason they can't access that
solution or it's not available to them
or they're unaware that it exists yeah I
mean I didn't get diagnosed with this
until I was 33 and I'm pretty sure that
I've dealt with it for my whole life
well it had to be so acute and severe
because from the outside looking in you
were excelling and succeeding and
perhaps on some level that was a
strategy that you developed to kind of
keep it at Bay or um you know minimize
your need to kind of confront it
certainly in some ways it was you know
it was working for me until it really
wasn't working for me and I had to hit
this ultimate low until I could or until
I yeah sought out help yeah well it's
really powerful for you to share it like
this and to use your platform to talk
about these things um and it is like a a
a testament to that service-minded
aspect of of who you are um and rather
courageous because you are competing
against these people and you must think
like well are they going to are people
going to try to weaponize this against
me in the in the kind of you know mental
Warfare of elite you know
Athletics yeah I you know I never really
thought about it in that way I never
thought like oh this might give my
competitors an edge over me I have this
really
kind of profound confidence in my abil
my athletic abilities and sometimes I
struggle with like confidence on a
day-to-day basis but like intrinsically
I have this deep belief that I am
excellent at what I do and if I am on my
day kind of doing what I know how to do
I'm really hard to beat and it'll be
really hard for somebody else to get in
the way of that
so I yeah I never it never really
occurred to me
that this could be like used against me
on the race course I was I was maybe
more afraid of like being judged by my
peers um but but not in a performance
sense when that New York Times article
came out I mean it's not like a random
blog or like the trucky local newspaper
like it's the New York Times you must
have been inundated with emails or
people calling you like what was the
response you know from your
perspective my poor husband I always
have these crazy ideas and he's really
supportive but sometimes he has to tell
me like Chelsea I think you don't need
to do this to yourself do we really need
this in our life right now it's
complicated enough yeah right so about
so I mean I was really struggling like
all through the winter off season and
didn't really get my together until
about four weeks out for my first race
last year which was Oceanside that's
when I was really able to like start
training properly and the article came
out on the Thursday before the race and
that week I also there had been another
um mass shooting in Tennessee at a
school and I decided to donate all of my
prize money from Oceanside to this
organization called Mom's demand action
which is really amazing like they work
on legislation to improve gun laws in
this country to make things safer for
for kids and families um so I you know
did this Public Announcement kind of
encouraging people to Rally behind this
organization and I was going to donate
my prize money from Oceanside and then
uh the New York Times article came out
the next day and I think I mostly just
you know turned social media off for for
a couple of days but for the most part
it was received really well and I got a
lot of um positive feedback and social
media is such an amazing way to connect
with other people but you know it was
alarming also how many people reached
out and told me their own stories with
some of the things that they they were
struggling with so um I I know that I am
not alone and there's a lot of other
people out there like me yeah you're
definitely not so how do you how do you
kind of uplevel this now and and and
really kind of institutionalize this
desire you have to you know Advance the
conversation around mental health and
and also uh female equity and
Sport yeah I mean it's an
evolving process there are some really
great organizations out there doing
awesome work um we spoke about my part
partner Canyon a bit earlier but they're
a German bike brand and they're very
Progressive they've been incredibly
supportive as me as a mom and we
partnered together on this amazing bike
my Kona race bike it's called the
rainbow explosion yeah it's it's really
quite something I'll I'll like finding
there's you know like bike Geeks they
there's always pictures of you know
people like yourself in their bikes and
there's there's lots of you know images
out there of this spectacular bike so
there's so much attention on our race
bikes at the World Championships there's
all these articles written about you
know what we're running and I thought
okay great like they're going to talk
about all my components what if we can
also attach another cause to this
project and Canyon was generous enough
to partner with an mother it's an
organization that was founded by Alicia
Montano she is an Olympian multiple time
um national champion in the a00 meters
and she did this um New York Times oped
in 2019 I think called dream maternity
talking about her experiences as an
athlete and and what that looked like
when she she became pregnant and it it
was not pretty she did didn't she didn't
get great support and so this
organization they give grants to
postpartum female athletes they work to
set up lactation stations and free child
care at races and events and they also
consult with companies on how to
integrate like effective and fair
maternity policy so Canyon made me this
beautiful race bike it um took 60 hours
to paint I believe and they made a
replica that were um kind auctioning off
through the sweep Stakes where people
can enter and um win my bike yeah that's
pretty cool that so it was hand painted
that it took that long to hand paint it
that's yeah and and the like the best
part of course in all of this is the
people and I've gone to be good friends
with the woman who painted my bike her
name is Cena and she is an incredible
artist it's all like hand marbled and we
worked a lot together on on the design
she would text me different swatches of
carbon and um it really like came to
life in this beautiful project it has
these epic DT Swiss Wheels with like
special pink logos and ceramic speed did
a habiscus derailer so it has all of the
fancy things on there but just a little
bit fancier yeah that's that's so cool
so lactation stations and Child Care at
races for women yeah so seems like a Nob
brainer I think so too I I had this
crazy experience a week out from Kona I
was going out for a swim you know at the
pier on the race start and there's this
woman standing in the shallow part
breastfeeding her kid as you do when you
have a baby and you're at the beach and
they need to eat they're hungry and I go
up to and go are you racing next weekend
and she says I am racing actually um I
qualified for Kona when my kid was 4
months old and I attached my breast pump
to my bike and I pumped in transition so
that I could like get on oh my
god with the run and the crazy this is
spooky this is really spooky and I don't
think she'll mind me sharing this but
she goes I just need you to know my name
is Chelsey and my daughter's name is Sky
and I was like if that's not some weird
like Cosmic connection I don't know what
is so that yeah the whole like Universal
synchronicity Dave Scott thing you know
just got you know escalated right yeah
so I I feel that it's a no-brainer I
don't know in
Triathlon we do have an equity problem
at a lot of these races you know it's
75% men and 25% women and I don't think
that's because women don't want to do
Triathlon I think that it's because they
don't have access or they don't feel
welcomed and things like lactation
stations or things like Child Care could
make a really big difference just to say
to mothers like you matter and we want
you here and you are accepted as part of
our community those sort of things are
barriers to entry and like I remember
pumping at the start of my you know
first triathon postpartum and it was
gnarly and like you don't really know
how to handle yourself in that situation
and you know I would have used that sort
of service right these or these you know
races these organizations their
governing bodies it's it's pretty much
mostly men right like it doesn't occur
to a man like oh we should have that
right right and that's why this is part
of why exactly and that's of course why
you know we need more women in
leadership positions and women need
there are changes like like the PTO has
done you know like they've made strides
right they have maternity leave and you
took advantage of that right like so
some progress has been made but
obviously there's a lot more that could
be done absolutely and it's amazing what
the PTO has done with the paternity
leave policy um but it's also 2023 and I
I think that's like the tip of the
iceberg there's so much more what about
at the elite level in terms of how it
all goes down qualifying for a race like
Kona has it been a good thing to
separate the men's and the women's races
to kind of better highlight um the
women's field and is is the
qualification process of getting into
the world championships the same as it
is for men and because it it seems so
Byzantine to me and I'm not paying super
close attention but I know obviously you
have to have a certain number of wins
and points and whatever to to to qualify
and I remember maybe it was a couple
years ago that it it did seem to be out
of balance in terms of how that operated
for women versus the men's field yeah so
we have um it's a slot kind of
qualifying system where you need to
place it depends on the race and how
many slots they're offering at that
event but you need to place first
through third let's say at an Iron Man
and that qualifies you forona there's
not a a point system anymore more and I
believe that we are getting kind of
equal numbers of qualifiers now the
whole you know separation of the men and
women's days and locations has been
controversial but I I believe it's
really important
because we deserve to have the stage at
the high highest level of racing I think
it's Antiquated to think that we all
need to be out there racing together you
see every other professional sport and
the women have their own world
championships I think the women's US
Open got better viewers in tennis got
better viewership than the men's US Open
we see what happened with the Women's
World Cup in Australia this year I mean
stadiums were packed and sold out and
and this year um more people T tuned
into the women's stream than the men's
stream for the Iron Man World
Championships right yeah wow so you know
the women really turned up up this year
and and put on a show I
think
97% of the athletes finished which is
super rare and um and you know the the
demand is there I think that when we are
on the course by ourselves we don't have
you know interference from the back end
of the men's professional field and and
the front end of the amateur field and
then we also get all of the media
attention on us we get proper you know
like officiating of the race so so I
think that in this next phase of growing
the sport and trying make it like a
truly professional sport we really need
the spotlight what are some of the other
changes that if you had your DRS or you
were the big boss in charge that you
would
make I I think that there is some some
loow hanging fruit like like we talked
about with you know lactation stations
and child care I think that you know
maternity policy should be standard
practice across you know industrywide I
think that there should be I don't know
the exact details of race deferral
options right now but I think that there
needs to be fair race deferral
opportunities for people who get
pregnant they shouldn't have to feel
like they're they need to like rush back
in order to qualify for races or so in
other words you you qualify for the
World Championships you get pregnant you
can say well I'm going to set this aside
and I have like an automatic in like
next year or the year after exactly yeah
exactly I think that there there's just
too much pressure to have to get back
quickly and um there is there is more
support right now but I think
that I think that it needs to be kind of
taken up level is there a another sport
out there outside of triathlon that you
think is is is doing a good job or
leading the charge when it comes to
these types of issues that could be a
model or is it across the board kind of
thing I think it's across the board I
think that the WNBA does have
amazing um like has maternity leave
policy they do things like they have an
egg freezing program the hard part about
Triathlon is that long-distance
Triathlon is that we're not governed by
a national body so it's it's difficult
just to decide like these things are not
free right it's it's hard to decide who
is going to like fund these programs but
but yeah in my perfect world we have an
egg freezing program so that we can
choose motherhood and have that option
whenever we want whether it's in the
middle of our careers or or afterwards
you know we have robust maternity leave
policies so that people like me don't
feel like they need to race when they're
four months postpartum like I would not
I'm not I don't have regrets but like I
don't remember a lot of the first year
of my daughter's life because I was
training so much and so tired and all
these things so um we have work to do I
have a couple questions about training
okay the physical part of training
very data driven with your coach um I'm
interested in the mindset piece like do
you have specific things that you do to
hone the mental game or mantras or
tricks or a practice that you think
gives you an advantage or or keeps you
on that fine edge of
competitiveness I do have some specific
practices that are more kind of
Performance Based this past year I
actually got into like a diaphragmatic
breathing meditation instead of the viic
meditation because I did some like
testing on myself about like what would
raise my raise my HRV the most um and it
was better with diaphragmatic breathing
versus The viic Meditation but I almost
think that that was a little bit of a
mistake I have a hard time checking out
from my work and I
think it's hard to recover when your
mind is always on and it's important for
me to create space between like my job
and my life and
so that was maybe a misstep the whole
idea of like viic meditation is that
it's not about like self-improvement and
bettering yourself it's about
like bettering your community and the
world and it's almost like a selfless
act where his mind was like very perform
it's a performance oriented meditation
yeah it's an agenda driven meditation
yeah which speaks to you know the type A
you hypervigilant athlete but is sort of
a cross purposes with the whole idea of
meditation to begin with right and I I
talked to this yeah I know I talked to
this mental coach and he said I was like
explaining to him that kind of my
protocols and the things that I do and
he's like so what do you do like for
yourself just to relax and I couldn't
really come up with anything yeah that's
not
good and it was like when is the last
time you went on vacation and I couldn't
remember so I am very much a work in
progress uhhuh are you on vacation right
now kind of sort of actually sort of
yeah I had 90 minutes to just kind of do
whatever I wanted pretty we are going on
vacation we're going on vacation this
weekend with our very dear friends um
the bouet Magdalena
yeah she was she was your coach for a
while she was my coach yeah so she
coached me um my first couple of years
at Cal she was the assistant coach there
and talk about like luck to have someone
like that come in to my life she's just
the most remarkable person and has like
changed the whole trajectory of my life
I think but I got to see her qualify for
the Olympics when her child was 2 years
old and so I had this model of you know
what it could look like to choose
motherhood and professional sport and
then she coached me um when I graduated
from Cal for a couple of years and and I
would tag along with her to all of her
training sessions and I really got to
watch up close like how she operated and
how professional she was and she's
continued to be you know a mentor to me
and I feel really lucky to have her in
my life quite something in addition to
all of that she won Western States like
she's quite accomplished yeah and what's
always like so amazing to me is that
she's the most like gen generous
selfless person and yeah we've talked
about how selfish like endurance sport
can be and it's the opposite for her
she's so yeah so like giving and um so
she continues to be a model not just as
a mom and an athlete but with that
service kind of orientation yeah yeah
she she really does and um yeah whenever
I have like a big life decision she's
one of the first people that I call do
you still tape your goals to your
bathroom
mirror um yeah I use um a like dry erase
marker and I have this quote that just
always stays on there that my coach
actually said to me when I was kind of
in the later stages of my pregnancy and
it was sort of an off-the-cuff thing
that he didn't think much about it but
it really resonated with me and it says
make the most important thing the most
important thing and and what he was
trying to say was like you're going to
be getting back into training it's going
to be really tempting to go all in on
this but like you're a parent and like
your family is the most important thing
and like you need to stay true to your
values and what really matters even when
things start to get like serious with
training and racing and so that's really
stuck with me and then um I write sky
right underneath that as a a reminder
not that I need a reminder I see her
every day but like I like just have it
there in case you forget yeah and then I
um it says True Grit underneath that
which was my Mantra with Magda and um
and then I write whatever race is kind
of coming up it's silly on one level but
I think you know as you're brushing your
teeth in the morning and you look at
those things it really grounds you into
like what matters and there are so many
distractions in our in our world and I
oftentimes feel feel so pulled in so
many directions that it reminds me like
I've chosen these things that really
matter to me and they're hard and it
doesn't leave a lot of time and space
for other things but this is what fills
my cup and this is what yeah makes me
feel really fulfilled as a person
beautiful the Mantra make the most
important thing the most important thing
what's great about that is that can mean
whatever you want it to mean and that
definition can change with the various
seasons of Life absolutely and for me it
even changes throughout a year of course
my family is like always my priority but
when I'm getting ready for a race like
the World
Championships I go all in and I'm not as
present of a parent as I am during other
seasons of the year and I go to training
camp without my daughter and I really
like focus in on this one thing that I
want to achieve and when the race is
over like I'm a full-time mom for a
while and my focus is back on my family
so I think it's important to for us like
as busy as we all are to like give
ourselves permission to go all in on the
things that matter to us and and to not
feel so much guilt
and and to be okay with you know to be
okay with those choices more than okay I
mean it's it's powerful
counterprogramming to this social
narrative or social imperative that
we're all supposed to be living and
pursuing this Balanced Life and that is
where our aspiration should lie like
every every day every bucket should be
filled and you should be able to do that
effortlessly and everybody's happy and
your attention is is you know diffused
adequately so that you know all your
values are satisfied and it's not
reality for anyone and it's particularly
not helpful to somebody who's prone to
the extremes who actually does their
best work as a result of indulging in
those extremes and as somebody like
yourself who whose job and whose goals
and whose dreams are are deeply vested
in your ability to go all in In This
Very unbalanced way there's an
unconscious kind of guilt that you end
up like shouldering because you feel
like you're not supposed to be doing
that or that it's somehow indulgent or
or
irresponsible and it's really
um it's violent and it's pernicious and
so I think it's important to not just
say it's okay for you to do that but
like to be
boldly you know say the opposite which
is like this is what this is what I do
and I I like refuse to be kind of
coralled into feeling bad about it yes I
have other things that are important in
my life but right now this is what I'm
doing like are you instead of like are
you living a balanced life your life is
balanced in in in the macro like the
pendulum swinging it's just on a
day-to-day or even a week- to week basis
it may not look balanced to an outside
Observer but I think the point is that
it's not about balance as much as it is
presence with what is important to you
right are you super present with what
you're doing and when that's the most
important thing giving it your all and
then you you flick the switch and then
you're doing the same thing as a mom or
to the other
uh things in your life that that are
important right like I struggle with all
of these things so much because the you
know the life that my little family
lives is like very different than a lot
of people in some ways because it's
super extreme and you know we're on the
razor's edge of trying to achieve these
things but so much of it is like who you
surround yourself with and like them
accepting you as you are and they're all
they're all happy for you when you win
but there's a of judgment about how
you're living your life in the meantime
on the dayto day totally and you know
like we've certainly felt that from our
parent like our families and they you
know love us right but I think it's
different it's like a different kind of
life path that we've Chosen and um we're
not risk averse like we're not afraid to
make bold choices and go all in on these
kind of crazy dreams and exceptionalism
demands it yeah no absolutely but I
think why I do feel so lucky is that
there is no guarantee that it will work
out right and in so many ways like this
win last year in Kona like validated all
of these choices and this like sort of
crazy career path that I've been on and
that like Steve and I have been on but
we have been really lucky to have you
know people in our lives like Magda and
like my coach Dan ples who have like
accept us as we are and really
championed this approach and gone all in
on it with
us it's more complicated now than it was
a year or a year and a half ago because
there's a whole business side now that
you're managing on top of just the
performance aspect of being an athlete
so with the win and the success comes
responsibilities and obligations and
contracts and all of that that also uh
interfere with the day-to-day day kind
of focus on the thing that got you there
in the first place so how do you
approach that navigate that and also
keep your kind of balance in your mental
health in
check yeah I mean I work with really
really amazing people um in santara
group who who helped me manage that and
like I just have to give a huge shout
out to them because they have been Along
on this ride with me um they're great
Adam's amazing yeah I mean they've
really like championed maternity
policies like they're the ones who are
having those conversations saying like
this is how it is and how it needs to be
and so I'm super super grateful but
certainly like the job has gotten a lot
bigger and to have this sort of success
like in your 30s is much different than
you know when you're like 22 and so in
that sense I'm like Greatful that I
maybe have this level of appreciation
for the opportunities that I have what's
been challenging is you know I have a
decade of a career where I felt like I
had to say yes to everything because
like I was just trying to kind of scrape
by and I think you know when you say yes
to something you're saying no to
something else and for me when I'm
saying yes to things that means I'm
saying no to time with my kid and I'm
like really aware that you know she's
sky is two and a half it's super
precious time with her yeah and so
yeah like I'm torn I'm torn all of the
time between my career and my kid which
is not unique to me it's like all
parents deal with these things so um
it's about of course like sticking to my
values and what matters to me and what
gets me fired up I shared with you
before we started that yesterday uh we
hosted Mark Cavendish on the podcast so
it's interesting backtack kind of elite
athletes with with really powerful
mental health stor stories Mark's
documentary on Netflix
portrays um you know the high highs of
his career but this really dark you know
kind of dip that he took and his
decision to to kind of transparently and
publicly talk about his mental health
Journey while also still being in the
sport and pursuing very lofty goals um
and my experience of spending time with
him
yesterday uh you know the biggest
takeaway from that is is that he just
feels really happy in his life and he
understands what's important to him and
that what he's getting to experience Now
is really just gravy like he loves his
kids he's had this amazing career he's
very grateful for that he just loves
riding his bike and he's excited about
the season but his relationship to
outcomes and and the distance that he
has put between himself and like
external expectations because there's
this you know looming thing about like
breaking the record and all of that for
most tour to France wins he seems really
at peace with and and right-sized about
and so as I'm hearing you sharing I'm
kind of identifying a
similar um sensibility in that you just
are coming across like you're really
happy in your life like you have big
goals you have Ambitions there's a lot
of things for you still to do you're
early in your career right a lot of
things that you you know our intent on
on succeeding at and expressing but I
feel like you're you're you're
grounded and you have a good
understanding of like what's
important yeah I think I am still very
ambitious and I feel like I'm just
getting started in this Triathlon thing
and winning is really fun and I want to
have another big day like I did in Kona
last year because I like that you admit
that it's the best honestly it's so it's
so fun and it's also the best way to say
thank you to the people who are along
for this ride and I want another moment
like
that on the other hand I think that that
win in
Kona it like made this whole project a
success so there is this level of
Freedom you know on my good days there's
this level of Freedom where I feel like
I kind of did the thing that I wanted to
do and now I just get to have fun and
see what's possible I I say to Steve
sometimes like all I all I really want
is I want the freedom when I retire to
take a year off and have another baby
and not have to worry about like
training or work so I can really like
have that experience again of being
fully a fully present mom with my baby
and I think that you know I'm like in a
position now where like that's a real
that's super cool what is it that you're
working on like what is the obstacle
that's recurring for you that you know
you need to work on like what is next uh
kind of Master in this equation yeah I
have a big bike project ahead of me
going into 2024 our world championships
ises involve somebody hand painting
something for like an ungodly number of
hours I think or does it involve you
pedaling it I think more me P I think
more of me pedling it um
we're our world championships are in nce
so it's going to be a very different
kind of race than Kona it's a super
technical course with big climbs and and
desense and I'm excited about that
project I I get some criticism about my
bike like I have not ridden my bike very
well this year and but I feel I know
that I'm a really good cyclist so I'm
excited to keep on working on that and
show it on race day cuz I haven't been
able to like produce are you a good
climber like a more technical rider cuz
n will will you know be good for that
yeah no I think it really suits me but
it will require some very specific
preparation but that'll be fun all right
yeah um any choice words for Lucy
Charles
Barkley about next year I just hope you
know I just hope that everybody um
Everybody shows up because I love I love
racing the best people on the biggest
stages and there's nothing more
satisfying than Breaking the tape when
everybody is there bringing their aame
what to your mind is the differentiator
between good and
great in Triathlon or just generally
well both
maybe you can start withon I think
what's so amazing
about the women side of the sport right
now is that it's it's like deeper than
it's ever been before you cannot have a
weakness I think maybe a decade ago you
could have you only had to be really
like good at two of the sports you could
maybe be like a little mediocre at one
thing but now you have to deliver across
all three you can't have a if you were a
great track and field Runner you could
immediately stand out which is what you
did but that's more rare these days you
have to be able to be the best in all
three right like you could yeah you
could be a good swim biker or a good
bike Runner but now you have to be a
really good Swim Bike Runner and so it's
amazing to see like the all of these
women rising to the
and the competition is so Fierce I think
you know there's 10 women that could win
on any given day so what is the
differentiator there assuming
everybody's great at everything you know
what is the what what who's the person
who only one person can win
yeah I mean I think that we all work
really hard it's about your belief in
yourself and the mental game that you
bring on that day one of my coaches
talked about how when you show up to a
world championship like a third of the
field doesn't think they can win a third
of the field has like messed up their
training and a third of the field
actually is there to race and at this
level now you have to be the full
package both Mind Body Spirit and you
can't have a weakness and so where are
you finding that extra Edge
then I think that I have
I have so much like belief in my
physical
ability whether that's true or not I
don't know but where does that come
from I think from my
training you know what I see on the day
today how Relentless I am that kind of
obsessive perfectionism that goes into
the small details you know like all the
little rehab exercises that people hate
doing like I love doing that stuff yeah
you're weird no nobody likes doing that
no one likes doing that stuff so I just
like love the day-to-day process
of improving and pushing
myself I think that I have work to do on
the mental game that's where I always
feel like there's something more to
unlock so what are we doing about
that yeah
um I yeah I was recently connected with
this amazing person his name is Dr David
Spindler yes and I think that you'll be
speaking with him pretty soon yeah we
have I don't know if he's scheduled yet
we've been speaking to him so he's the
sports psychologist that shows up in in
the Mark Cavendish documentary and was
instrumental and and helping Mark that
could be a good team member for you yeah
I'm really excited about what we might
be able to to do together so um I had a
like an awesome first chat with him but
then of course he had to like go through
the different team members so he talked
to Steve and then he talked to my coach
Dan and I think we're yeah all excited
about yeah what we could what we could
do together that's exciting yeah the
last thing I want to ask you about has
to do with change like the nature of
change because that's sort of probably
the most prominent kind of recurring
theme of this show like how do you go
from becoming one person to the more
inspirational version of yourself how do
you let go of bad habits and adopt
better habits what are the things that
um get in people's way in terms of
trying to transition or Elevate
themselves and as someone like yourself
you spoke today about you know going
from track and field to Triathlon going
from short course to long course but
more importantly weathering this you
know mental health situation that that
You' had to deal with to come out the
other side a champion healthy you've
earned a certain um you've earned your
transformation like you understand the
discomfort in the process of what's
demanded upon you or required in order
to elevate yourself out of one situation
and place yourself in the you know on a
trajectory that's putting you toward
your dreams do you think about the
nature of that itself or do you have any
thought thought that you could share as
we kind of close this up with somebody
who's listening or watching who knows
that maybe they need to change or they
should change or they have an ambition
or a goal but have trouble trying to
figure out how to kind of Kickstart
themselves into engaging with that
process Yeah by Nature I like we talked
about I'm a pretty anxious person and I
obsess and I overthink about things and
when I'm making a big decision or my
husband and I are making a big kind of
life decision he will always say to me
we don't make choices out of fear even
when things are scary or hard like we
you and me we are not going to make
these choices out of fear and I think
that that's something that I've done a
really good job of and he and I have
done a really good job of as this kind
of team is even when we are afraid or
things get hard
like we we are able to kind of transcend
that and and not make big
decisions based on fear and basing them
instead on
what I think basing them instead of
instead
on like joy and love and optimism and
possibility we're not risk averse and
that's probably to a fault sometimes our
choices have not worked out but like
like in the grand scheme of things we're
living this you know really Purpose
Driven fulfilling life and it looks a
little different than um maybe some of
the people that we grew up with or our
families but
um yeah I mean it's such an exciting
fulfilling way to live and and I think
that I feel so alive in the things that
I pursue even though it's not always
easy that's a pretty great place to
live yeah I mean I think like win or
lose right to know that that's the
alignment that you're always kind of
striving for in your life is
inspirational
thanks and I'm not always perfect right
and I fail all the time but I think that
my coach says to me actually it's like
Winston Churchill quote it's like um
it's something to the effect of success
is when you are able to go from one
failure to the next without losing
enthusiasm yeah and um like I mean most
athletes right we win we lose way more
than we win but we keep on coming back
for more because the journey is so
fulfilling and it's so fun and I have so
much curiosity about what's possible and
and sometimes that surprises me because
like I'm 34 which is it's not like young
in in professional sports but I still
feel like I'm just getting started and
there's so much to look forward to and
so much ahead super cool and uh if it
doesn't work out with Spindler your
husband you know for him to say we don't
make decisions based on fear I'm like
well he can be your sports psychologist
he seems more than qualified he's a
really he's a really smart guy
oftentimes often times they'll be
chatting through something with him and
he'll say I think that this is what you
should do and I'll be like I don't know
about that and then I'll talk to Dan my
coach and I'll say the exact same thing
I'm like you're right Dan exactly that's
exactly what I need to do it's great um
such a delight to talk to you today I'm
a huge fan I can't wait to see what is
in store for you um in the year and in
the years ahead uh so it was really cool
getting to know you a little bit and
thank you for sharing I think I think
your message is really powerful uh I
think your your instinct and your
inclination to lean into the mental
health discussion
and and really leverage your platform
for good in that area and in terms of
Greater equity and sport is is is
laudable and beautiful and I'm at your
service if there's anything I can do to
help you so thank you thank you all
right until next time go go out there
and win and come back and tell me all
about it sounds like a good plan
peace that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change in
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. roll.com if
you'd like to support the podcast the
easiest and most actul thing you can do
is to subscribe to the show on Apple
podcasts on Spotify and on YouTube and
leave a review Andor comment supporting
the sponsors who support the show is
also important and appreciated and
sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find find on
the footer of any page at Rich roll.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason Cameo with a digal audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Blake Curtis with assistance by our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Davy Greenberg graphic and social media
assets courtesy of Daniel CIS thank you
Georgia for copywriting and website
management and of course our theme music
was created by to Patt Trapper Patt and
Harry mathys appreciate the love love
the support see you back here soon peace
plance
[Music]
namaste